[Musique]
je m'appelle Dominique Verrien je suis
sénatrice de Lyonne et conseillère
municipal de saint-sauveran puis je suis
devenue sénatrice en 2017 et j'ai été
réélu en
2020 quand j'ai souhaité rentrer à la
délégation au droits des femmes c'était
comme suffragette c'est-à-dire pour dire
on peut faire les mêmes choses que les
gar il faut arrêter et en fait je suis
arrivée au moment où on a commencé à
travailler sur la loi contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes je me
suis beaucoup engagé sur la lutte contre
les violences intrafamiliales j'aime
bien avoir cet équilibre faire valoir la
femme qui
réussit tout en essayant de protéger
celle qui est
victime ce besoin m'est venu en
rencontrant une femme qui était une
accoucheuse de rue être femme sans abri
c'est beaucoup plus de risque de se
faire faire frapper de se faire violer
et donc de tomber enceinte c'est un
phénomène qui
augmente donc il est important qu'on
étudie pourquoi comment et surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire de formation effectivement je suis
ingénieur en travaux publics sur 150
élèves dans ma classe nous étions 15
filles j'ai commencé chez Colas à aller
construire des route et puis rapidement
ensuite je suis passée en maîtrise
d'œuvre puis en maîtrise d'ouvrage
j'étais assez passionné par la façon
dont on construisait la ville et
finalement qui pense la ville sinon les
politiques donc c'est plutôt par
l'urbanisme que je suis arrivée à la
politique je suis vraiment tombée
amoureuse de Saint- Sauveur en Puiset je
ne suis pas peu fière d'être la première
femme mèire de la commune de colollette
c'est une femme extraordinaire qui était
très libre qui a tout essayer parce que
tout était possible en fait et c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on fasse passer à toutes
nos petites filles aujourd'hui c'est
tout est possible si on a envie de faire
il faut jamais hésiter il faut y
[Musique]
aller faut apprendre à travailler 7
jours sur 7 on a 423 communes et que 52
weekends donc autant dire qu'il y a des
choses tous les weekends tous les
weekends tous les weekends moi j'adore
ce que je fais donc j'ai pas trop de
problème ça ça me pèse pas mais chaque
petite avancé chaque petit pas est un
pas qui nous amène effectivement vers
plus de reconnaissance de ce que c'est
que la ruralité les territoires grâce au
Sénat sont mieux reconnus et donc je
suis vraiment très heureuse de siéger au
[Musique]
Sénat